up next we got some relationship advice
same guy
this is from nineteen year old zip Oh
1900 Wow the model you mean it's a model
man it's a young boy hopefully she can
hear you
no no gang bang bro you're 19 don't
gangbang well he can do what he wants
first of all first of all I'd say speak
up because your girls have no idea if
you like her or not cuz you're
whispering to us
so I'd say speak up third thing is
you're 19 yeah best man wins dude roll
out the red carpet
take her to MC theatres get the Red
Vines get your dick out in the popcorn
aisle you know I'm saying go see Lion
King [ __ ] French kiss in the back
yeah you know I'm saying may the best
man win
shield up don't give it to that yeah may
the best man win man you can't like
there's no I'll tell you this while
you're sending this video and your boy
is sending her a message bro you gotta
get in there bro and get the action be
that action Jackson bro don't be that
[ __ ] dead in bin you know so you got
to really take care of yourself bro you
you know like if you got a kid though
here's the swag going on I'm saying good
looking kid dude I'm a [ __ ] adult and
I don't look at children like that you
seem like a male I'll say that and you
seem you know like you're alive now it
also seemed like you could be in hiding
right now because you're talking at a
very unique decibel known to people that
are playing hide-and-go-seek oh my god
even be 18 but the lady man first of all
it sounds like you both have never met
her it's like you just know from
snapchat let's go to a woman's
perspective poor cat culture corner
what's up okay
I mean I agree with you guys best man
wins guys are 19 you guys need to duke
it out [ __ ] race run a 40-yard dash
no everwood's fight you idiot you're not
fight you don't need to fight ray
each other but also she probably has her
mind up about who she likes more does
she she's 18 yes where she can motor
bike it this if there are two choices
you always want one a little more than
the other Oh always oh wow
he does have some swag I told you the
good-looking kid I'd like to see the
other kid and then when maybe we can
think we can pick for her you want to
see the other kid
yeah maybe set there eight it's how many
young kids you see today guy huh we're
not just one I'm gonna predict a winner
I think when we do a key afternoon
sponsor date the little twink hunter
yeah we'll send him on a date actually I
think it's not a bad idea to do a date
and have a sentence and video from it
but I want to know this do you think
cats say if say if she likes the other
guy more like you said maybe they like
the woman might already know right yeah
what's his move if he's the guy in
second place how does he play at a batch
ance maybe even down the road like what
is his them what are the mistakes he
could make and what are the things he
could actually do correctly I mean just
because she likes the other guy a little
more doesn't necessarily mean he's out
of the race he's just got to step up his
game
you mean like get more Instagram
followers she linked up with long
they're kazoom [ __ ] Wow I mean you just
can't mentally challenged boy under the
[ __ ] Brendan [ __ ] he's not
mentally challenged yes he is dude he's
a nice dude I know he's nice he's also
mentally generally yeah he does two
things you know you're trying to throw
them under your little [ __ ] scooter
or whatever you're driving these days
you're a little [ __ ] you talk about I
saw you with your second scooter pic the
other day you [ __ ] animal doing
wheelies on it yeah I don't know cats
you can pick up give him some advice cat
cuz this [ __ ] guy looks like he's
about to slit his own wrists
definitely don't split your own wrists
thank you gonna be okay advice it gets
better nice to these kids nowadays bro
winter doesn't come they [ __ ] kill
themselves man dude yeah if you for it
and you picked up our second season 70
kids kill themselves well there's a new
documentary out this mate says it's cool
to kill yourself 13 reasons to kill your
buddy or whatever it is
weird man it's like hey kids here's a
cool idea
make some [ __ ] tapes and [ __ ] off
yourself if then dad doesn't like their
pictures they off themselves it just
times are different man different man so
at least this guy has the balls to reach
out to some [ __ ] guys who have really
made some shitty decisions like Brendan
and myself that's why we had cat
throwing that suggestion so he's not out
of it cat he can still win this race he
could still win he just got to figure
out what she wants I mean at that age if
I got I was real simple if you bought me
boba and popcorn chicken I was yours
damn god damn girl yeah well nobody did
it that's the thing that's the thing
boba and chicken yes we can try chicken
but pop yeah she's good deep-fried
popcorn chicken Jesus weird that from
Derrick where are you gonna [ __ ] me
headed there I'll do this you're an
idiot man I'm an idiot and you're a
racist I'm a racist dude you're an idiot
yeah and you're racist idiot let's give
this guy a cigarette whatever dude
you're out of your mind
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]